a lot of breaking developments today on
the sexual misconduct scandals rocking
the country Charlie Rose has been fired
by CBS n PBS and multiple allegations of
harassment by former staffers have been
made meanwhile the longest-serving
member of the House is now under
scrutiny Michigan Congressman John
Conyers admits to settling harassment
complaint against him in 2015 but denies
the allegations were true al franken
keeping a low profile after a second
woman comes forward with groping
allegations and then there was this
president Trump commenting publicly
earlier about Alabama Senate candidate
Roy Moore he's not calling for him to
drop out of the race I can tell you one
thing for sure we don't need a liberal
person in there a Democrat Jones I've
looked at his record it's terrible in
crime he denies it look he denies it I
mean if you look at what what is really
going on and you look at all the things
that have happened over the last 48
hours he totally denies it I'll be
letting you know next week but I can
tell you you don't need somebody who's
soft on crime like John Roy Moore denies
it that's all I can say he denies it
women are very special I think it's a
very special time because a lot of
things are coming out and I think that's
good for our society and I think it's
very very good for women and I'm very
happy a lot of these things are coming
out and I'm very happy I'm very happy
it's being exposed
I don't know look I don't want to speak
for Al Franken I don't know I don't know
what happened I just heard about Conyers
two minutes ago
as far as frankenz concerned he's gonna
have to speak for himself okay so the
president making a you know public
comment on this now saying that Roy
Moore Greg denies the allegations so he
is not I guess also sharing the
sentiment that his daughter Ivanka Trump
which is being used in a campaign ad now
against run waterers against Ryan
whereby his opponent I don't know where
to start in the beginning well yeah in
the beginning there was Charlie Rose
he's clearly the oldest the fact that
Charlotte the whole thing with Charlie
Rose is so strange that he would like
like force co-workers our young people
to view him naked like he would walk
around the apartment naked and now we as
Americans have to see that in our in our
head as well and all I can see is one of
those hairless cats on hind legs smoking
a pipe I'm really glad I went to you
know you should have gone to me because
I'm comply
that all this stuff is happening so fast
and there's all these different types
and we're not prioritizing which is
which and this guy had five luxury homes
how did he he worked for public
broadcasting our direct taxes pay for
this guy's lightning that's the real
scandal no no I think I just the whole
thing is just so bad and then you've got
this other everything that he's got
Franken it's like people act like this
stuff with Frank it is new all you gotta
do is go on YouTube you know look up
Howard Stern's interview with him in
1999 and you'll find other people this
was not a secret he talked about it
mmm-hmm I was a good point so Dana you
know where do we go from here and what
did you think of the president's
messaging on this that he did finally
make a statement then but he didn't go
so far as to say he was in a campaign
for Roy Moore said he's not the
allegations who to get back to everybody
next week as to whether or not he'd be
campaigning well I think he all but said
he's going to campaign for him he's like
I'll get back to you next week what's he
gonna do now like unless you cross the
threshold week at this point you're
basically saying I'm good no problem
well for me hard pass I also think it's
a heck of an argument to be leaving well
you have you're right on the cusp of
having tax reform done before the
election
before Roy Moors even voted on you you
actually had the chance to get tax
reform done without him regardless and
you actually have really good messaging
and you have members of Congress all
talking on the same wavelength
everybody's working hard and on your in
your favor and we're in the middle of
this society altering hurricane and he
didn't need to step into the middle of
it today but he did and now there's
really there's no going back and I hope
that he will give people a pass because
every single Republican is going to be
asked do you agree with President Trump
on Roy Moore and they're going to have
to make their own decisions and if they
say no I hope he will understand that
that is just going to have to be the way
it is it's not personal but this is a
decision that they made the RNC has
already walked away from him there's no
money so now all of a sudden and then
the president is saying that well yeah
maybe I'll go and campaign for him I
think that this is something that he
actually didn't need to do but now that
having done it there will be
consequences for it it doesn't mean that
Roy Moore won't win it's well it's
likely that he could win in Alabama and
the thing is also I just under Jones his
opponent I don't accept that he is weak
on crime I would say that the stronger
argument for a lot of people in Alabama
is that he is very pro-choice and so on
if you're if you care about reproductive
rights you would probably want to go
ahead and vote for Doug Jones but if you
are a pro-life person when there was
many of them in Alabama then Roy Moore
would be your choice because if you are
a single issue voter I think it is that
I don't think it's necessarily crime
giving Doug Jones background he might
have picked a different tax is that the
president yeah I definitely think if you
want to go against if you want to run
against doug jones and you want to
figure out the issue to focus on maybe
their message testing tells him it's
crime but his background doesn't back
that up given all that he's done as a
former US Attorney and prosecuting
racist in particular but I do expect
that President Trump will go with
campaign for him and we'll just have to
see where at least see what happens all
right Jesse what do you make of the
president's statement pretty stunning
developments this guy went from
extremely toxic two weeks ago more to
now
lately less toxic to the point where the
president United States it's kind of
keeping them at arm's length a little
bit not fully endorsing them but not not
endorsing a minute at all very
surprising it looks like it's a
free-for-all now because like Dana said
the RNC is here but he's still raising
money independent of the RNC and the
prediction markets are actually
predicting that Roy Moore does win and
the lesson if you listen to what the
president said is if you deny the
allegations you get the benefit of the
doubt in politics
that's a strange barometer I think going
forward it's very different in politics
versus the private sector the private
sector the mere accusation goodbye in
politics either get sent to an ethics
committee you know maybe you pull an
endorsement but the guy will still be
alive right now it comes down to pure
raw power politics do we want to keep
the Senate Majority the Republicans are
thinking or do we want to take the moral
high ground and you know maybe save face
and fight for another day and that's the
calculation all these Republicans have
to make by themselves interesting okay
so one were you surprised by the
residents you know comments and where do
you come down on this welcome our
suppliers on several levels one is just
on a human level I don't
I mean if it's my daughter 14 years old
I mean come on that's not politics I
mean there's this let's do away with the
tribal political thing here oh I'm a
Republican I gotta back this guy because
of abortion right wait a minute you're
an evangelical and Alabama is gonna
support a candidate who was supposedly
messin out the 14 I mean and they don't
they don't believe the women I don't
care I mean there was one of the women
who was on TV went on the Today Show
it's not like people are hiding I mean
you have people saying you know what
these this is these are credible charges
serious charges I believe that you have
the Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell saying I believe the women
that's a serious step you know jesse was
talking about the political calculation
all that but at some level you got to
stop and say wait a minute I'm a human
being a 14 year old or young women
he says yeah generally remember you when
I shown here generally I didn't mess
around with younger what is going on
when people can't see something so
obvious sitting in front of them it's
alarming to me but let me just you know
pick up in general yeah I think the
president then it is the way I felt when
he tweeted about Al Franken on a
political level why is he doing that
because it opens the door to charges
about him and questions about his past
behavior Gregg said oh you just have to
go back and listen to Frank anon Howard
Stern go back and listen to Donald Trump
on Howard Stern mm-hmm I mean and you've
got 1999 oh yes you have yeah but I mean
you've got these cases sitting there now
and so everybody's gonna go back and say
well wait a minute Donald Trump now is
some sort of authority he has no moral
authority on this issue
but it's a difference I guess I would I
guess when Franken was on Stern my dad
they talked about the things that he did
and it was it's pretty interesting he
had problems trying to defend it and
it's just sitting there yeah but I'm
saying so is Trump stuff sitting there
and nobody you know for the moment
people like let it go now the big
Republican argument has been well the
American people elected him yeah so I
guess it was lit well actually hasn't
been litigated nobody has sat down and
gone through it but now you are because
I think there's like a dozen plus women
who have charges against the president
one final point this is really about
Republican infighting Steve Bannon has
stayed by judge Moorside kiv the
governor the Alabama Republican Party
stayed by his side
I find this bizarre but it's true the
National Republican Party understands
this will be a probiem that will be hung
around their necks for all time and they
understand how it's going to be damaging
to them and to their brand I don't want
to get them we don't have time to run
them the sound of a but you know let's
talk about kind of the reaction what you
thought of the women of SNL they came
out to support Al Franken in light of
these groping allegations well I have
mixed feelings about that if they
weren't coerced into signing their names
onto something or intimidated into
signing their names on something or if
they say that you didn't sign it and
then you were intimidated that way
I'm not for that right at all I don't
think that's right and I also am
concerned like this idea that if you
deny it then you're gonna be fine
Conyers just did the same and then
they're like well wait what about that
you're there is actually a settlement
it's like oh that settlement right okay
so oh right that's what you're talking
about so if you're a woman who feels
like you have been wronged and something
that something bad happened to you why
would you come forward because if you
know that the man is going to deny it
and they're going to be fine and your
reputation is the one that's going to
suffer like Ida I don't like any of this
but I also go back to that we are this
is truly a society altering event we
joke this morning and we're talking
about like getting a kind of joke but
putting together the show for this
afternoon mid-morning like what are we
going to lead with and I said well wait
till this afternoon and there will be
something bigger there sure enough
there's another person from Disney who
is stepping down amidst allegations so I
don't know if we need a new definition
of what actual harassment is I think
it's interesting that so many companies
are waiting until the new story they
know is coming before they actually do
something but I hope that for the women
that have decided to come forward with
with true allegations that they feel
that they can get some restitution and I
don't mean reparations necessarily but
something that will quiet their mind so
that they can move on with their lives
in a healthier way and not have to have
this hanging over them like a lot of
these people if they are victimized they
carry it through their lives the whole
time and you see you see it over and
over again with people who have been
victimized that end up having problems
later on because they didn't deal with
it then hopefully there's enough
companies out there including the
Congress that needs to change its laws
so that you don't have to wait 180 days
so you can actually have the secret
mediation and then maybe not get any
restitution for another 30 days and then
another 30 days when you could do it by
that time you might as well quit and
move on or you get fired which is what
happened to the young woman that worked
for Charlie Rose all right I see you
guys quick comments well yeah I mean you
know we talked about victims and we
talked about this in a very broad way
but if we don't have a systematic
assessment of accusation right then the
spectrum from a bad joke at a bar or a
clumsy pass to all-out assault because
part of this whole world which is not
does not fairly benefit the victim the
victim of serious stuff who is then
lumped together with the victim if
somebody makes a crass joke so it
doesn't benefit the victim or the
accused categories are important because
as piggish says al franken is he's not
weinstein and as stupid and creepy as
glenn thrushes he's no James Toback and
we have to somehow slow it down separate
the accusations maybe allow for a
defense
you know maybe why not and then address
the capacity for change if somebody says
that that's the way they were and
they're not that way anymore you know we
talk about a forgiving Society we
certainly the media isn't the media the
media will eat their own for a story
brings up great points the issue when
you say you a call for a defense but for
you know due process I have some kind of
adjudication or some kind of
understanding of the merits and what's
true and and what is it because it's
very different when I see it you know
juxtaposed to like the court of law you
actually get a trial you know and by a
jury by your peers you get to be able to
put on a defense and you get to be able
to do a proper you know investigation
and that's what makes it so difficult
because it's not in the legal system he
said she said there's a lot of this
happens alone one on one and the only
lesson I can think of just off the top
of my head when you said what do we
learn from this where do we go forward
if you're a woman and you feel like you
have been inappropriately touched or
groped or you feel sexually harassed or
abused in any way in any setting you
immediately immediately have to come
forward and tell someone tell a
girlfriend tell a boyfriend make a
friend Superior make a complaint with HR
because to not say anything and let
weeks and months and years pass by that
everybody's memory goes haywire people
don't believe you as much and then it
comes out of the blue people question
the timing and there's no way to
corroborate anything so I would just
that be my advice to people I'm just
saying I think people in the Charlie
Rose case did go to the supervisor and
now she says she wish she had done a
better job of speaking up for these
young women and in the Trump case one
and said they went right away and said
something in Trump has by his own
language said he was grabbing women if
it's a good-looking woman
you just run up in care I mean this is
his own language